[موسيقى]
تنقسم النجوم الى قسمين نجوم استدلاليه
وهي النجوم التي نستدل بها على الجهات
وعلى الفصول والمواسم ونجوم ارشاديه وهي
النجوم التي ترشدنا الى النجوم
الاستدلاليه وعلامات وبالنجمهم يهتدون
فالهدايه هنا هدايه مشاهده وهدايه معنويه
عقائديه فالنجوم هي القنطره التي توصلنا
الى الله سبحانه وتعالى ولينظروا ماذا في
السماوات والارض وما تغني الايات والنذر
عن قوم لا يؤمنون فالارض وما تحتويه من
جبال ومخلوقات والسماء من نجوم
ومجرات دليل قاطع على عظمه الله سبحانه
وتعالى فلا ينظرون الى الابل كيف خلقت
والى السماء كيف وفعت والى الجبال كيف
نصبت والى الارض كيف سطحت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والنجم القطبي الذي يسميها العامه بالجدي
يدلنا على الشمال وهو النجم الاوحد الذي
لا يغيرها مكانه ليش لانه يقع فوق محور
دوران الارض حول نفسها وبنات نعش المسماه
بسبع يرشد اننا عليه وسهيل يدلنا على
الجنوب وين نجم سهيل يا نجم الجدي
طيحتي من عينه
ارفع للمقام
[موسيقى]